I'm joined today by Rachel Levin who's
an investigative reporter for the
nonpartisan nonprofit newsroom the
Center for Public Integrity and today
we're going to talk about pollution
pollution is an issue Rachel that I mean
it ties in to so much of what we're
talking about on what we've been talking
about for a long time in particularly
under the new EPA it relates to climate
change it relates to business regulation
it relates to so many important topics
but we actually need to sort of think
about can we even know the degree to
which industry and automobiles are
polluting the United States in principle
how would we look up that information
what source of in what sources do we
have to figure out how much pollution
we're putting out
sure so the EPA has a lot of data on its
website things like the toxics release
inventory which is supposed to show
toxic pollution from major polluters
industrial polluters and there's also
inventories like the greenhouse gas
inventory which would show emissions
planet warming emissions from major
polluters as well and as a general sort
of overview of that what really is being
measured by that data and what is sort
of not part of that data or what can we
not ascertain from those numbers I think
the question that you're asking is you
know how what do those numbers contain
and so some of them basically they
contain estimates of pollution that's
coming out of those facilities but some
of those facilities report direct
numbers that are measured and others
basically use formulas and modeling to
estimate what their emissions are but
they don't actually test those emissions
and put that number out for public
consumption is that the primary source
of sort of where the reality might
differ from the numbers that we get or
is there more to why the numbers that
ultimately go public may not be accurate
or trustworthy
well so the crux of the air program at
the EPA is this program focused on
emission factors and they're these tools
that basically the EPA has used since
before it was called the EPA to guess at
how much pollution is coming out of some
kinds of facilities and so those
emission factors are used in the
modeling done by these facilities and
that goes to showing the final overall
number for pollution but the emission
factors were intended to show basically
averages they were intended to be used
in a different way than they're being
used now a lot of times individual
facilities are using this information to
guess their own emissions rather than
the EPA saying in a given state there
are this many facilities and we expect
that on average this is what their
pollution would be so if you're
listening to this if someone in the
audience hears you talking about this
they say okay so data that's been really
release may not accurately reflect how
much pollution is being pumped into our
atmosphere but how does that directly
affect me can you talk about that a
little bit and the basis on which
permits for individual factories in
someone's town or nearby might have been
approved or denied based on this type of
data yeah so there are a lot of ways
that these kind of estimates can affect
individuals so for one thing your state
regulators are probably using the same
emission factors as these that were
developed on the federal level and a lot
of those actually come from industry or
are based on industry information so the
EPA and a lot of times is relying on
someone else's information to come up
with these estimates and then these
estimates are then used by your state
regulators to decide how how to regulate
the pollution and to control pollution
coming out of industrial facilities that
are in your community an occasion
or often these emission factors are
actually used by individual facilities
to show how much pollution they expect
would come out of their facility and it
is used by the state and that facility
to decide what their pollution limits
should be but sometimes that doesn't
actually match up with what their
pollution is and so there's more
pollution in that community than a
permit would be allowing for or than
anyone would have expected is there any
way to estimate at sort of like the
aggregate or national level to what
degree
we're probably under estimating the
amount of pollution that is being pumped
into our atmosphere there isn't and it's
a really complex area right like this is
a difficult thing that the EPA has tried
to get its hands around and there's a
lot of complexities to it but for some
pollution for some pollutants there's
pretty clear-cut ways to know that if
you put this much of this kind of fossil
fuel for example into this kind of
facility we can pretty much guess what's
going to come out and it should be
relatively accurate so for some
pollution we know that they're
relatively accurate for other types of
pollution like methane for example
studies continuing have been continuing
to come out the basically show these
numbers are vastly off and a lot of the
studies that have come out by that have
been funded by the Environmental Defense
Fund but have been done in coordination
with a lot of industry and companies
show that that generally means that
there's a vast underestimation of
methane so for some these pollution
estimates are actually kind of on target
for others it's just it's widely off and
underestimated and that just means that
we don't have all the information that
we necessarily need to be making the
best decisions about how to protect
people's health but also how to prevent
global warming
more global warming than what we would
like we talked about regulatory capture
pretty often on the program the idea
that sort of people from industry end up
getting into positions as regulators of
the industry that they are supposed to
be regulating and the industry sort of
exerts disproportionate amount of
control over the regulation do you have
reason to believe that that's part of
why there is so much sort of taking
industry's word for how much they're
polluting is it more a lack of resources
on the behalf of the EPA is it a
combination of the two emission factors
are really interesting because they're
really hidden in every single regulatory
decision that we see or not every single
one but many of them so a lot of times
it's really a lack of resources when the
EPA has been developing these mission
factors over time it just takes a vast
amount of resources it could take like a
year of studies and if the EPA had their
way they would be doing all of these
studies and all of this work on their
own but just because of how much how
time intensive it is and how resource
intensive it is often they have to rely
on data that other people can give them
and they try to they do try to measure
for you know what quality that data is
but you know if someone else is doing
the testing there may be ways that they
would have liked to have done it
differently and you just have less
control over the information coming in
the other aspect of that is that once
these emission factors are put in place
the EPA doesn't have a ton of resources
to go back and look and check on them so
some of these may have been in place
since the 1980s and obviously best
available information now is much
different than best available
information about air pollution and the
1980s now at the level of like the
individual activists let's say you're an
individual you learn that there's going
to be a factory coming to where you live
there's going to be a community hearing
about it you show up you express concern
about pollution the industry
representative says nope here we go here
is the amount of pollution that this is
going to put out and here's how it's
going to be mitigated you're an
individual activist and you heard this
interview and you suspect that that
information
might not be accurate what can you
really do it's hard I mean these are
really complex datasets but what I would
say is that if you have concerns about
it go to your regulators ask them to
explain to you why that information is
correct express those concerns through
regulatory comment periods you know I
think that advocates have said that they
would like to see much more activity and
scrutiny by regulators but a lot of
regulatory action is actually driven by
the squeaky wheel who's the squeaky
wheel who's actually calling for this
attention to be made to certain issues
so a few concerns you can always reach
out to your regulators and some people
have had success reaching out to
companies as well like I would think
that a lot of companies are trying in
good faith to use these factors and they
may be using them as the only
information that's there to estimate
what their emissions would be so if you
have concerns you should see them as a
resource as well all right very
important topic and a complex one we've
been speaking with Rachel Levin who's an
investigative reporter for the Center
for Public Integrity thanks for talking
to us about this Rachel great thanks for
having me